robots are revolutionizing medicine
well not those robots they can work in
ways that humans cannot
in surgery they can be more sensitive
more precise
can scan for problems a human may not
see and they can draw on data from
procedures carried out by other robots
robots didn't get tired and the decision
making is consistent
but if they do make mistakes who is
responsible
is it the surgeon the robot manufacturer
the hospital
or some other person or thing
responsible
well this is what the irobot surgeon
survey
is trying to help with it's a survey
composed of five scenarios that are
entirely fictitious
in them a patient comes to harm and you
need to judge who is most responsible
well hello and welcome to the sheehy
science show where i recently did the
survey myself and thought it'd be
interesting to talk in this video
about robotic surgery because it's
definitely going to impact all of us
throughout
our lives probably at some point so
before we jump into these different
situations we first need to go through
the three different types of robotic
surgery
these different types differ by the
extent of automation of the robot
itself so the first type is human
controlled robot systems
secondly you have robot assisted systems
and lastly you have
fully autonomous robot systems so
regarding human controlled robot systems
this includes robots that are completely
controlled by the surgeon
who can sometimes be in a different
place to the surgery
and so these are known as telesurgical
robots other robots
are integrated within handheld
instruments
and may for example warn the doctor when
they are operating close to important
parts of the body
so these would be like hand-held robots
the example you may have heard of
includes the da vinci system that was
produced by intuitive surgical
and this has been used for a range of
different operations
including hysterectomy robot assisted
systems
would help the surgeon carry out
specific tasks
so parts of the operation that can be
done better by a robot than a surgeon
so for example because it's more precise
steady or agile
and so these could include things such
as stitching wounds inserting
a needle into the brain or inserting a
screw to fix a broken bone
the surgeon is present and would
therefore supervise the robot
and then as kind of given by the name
autonomous robot systems would be
machines that could complete surgery
with little or no supervision from a
human
and it's this type of robot that is
currently not used to perform surgery
so given this background information the
aim of the survey
is designed to give the respondents an
opportunity
to provide answers based on that
instinct of who they feel
shoulders the most responsibility and by
doing this this enables
a better understanding of whether there
is a perceived illness of responsibility
still placed in the human surgeon even
at robotic systems become increasingly
autonomous
as you might imagine depending on how
autonomous the robot is
your opinion might differ so at least at
the time of making this video
the survey is still open for people to
complete so
i put a link to the survey in the
description and
as you'll go through it you'll be
introduced to five different scenarios
where you'll have the opportunity to
make your decision
so obviously the point of this video is
not to to bias anyone's decision
and instead to just emphasize
the kind of dilemma that the the field
is currently facing
in terms of providing insights into
regulations and policies and would also
potentially help to direct future
research
and it's interesting to point out that
these kind of questions and challenges
are not just confined to the field of
surgery but also are being questioned in
terms of autonomous cars
and how you know if there was a crash
was it the fault of the driver
or was it the fault of a malfunctioning
of the system of the car
and was that due to the building of the
car in the first place or the initial
software programmers
who developed the self-driving
technology so whilst researching for
this video i also came across a couple
of like quite interesting and in-depth
reviews about this topic
and also just more generically talking
about the technology and
the level that we're at in terms of
robotic surgeons
which is pretty interesting so yeah
definitely check them out if you're
interested
but i think yeah the whole future of
this
you know robotic surgery is mainly to
put
the patient first and to put their
thoughts first in terms of having
minimally invasive surgery
which means that they can also recover
faster but it comes of the consequence
of putting that
that weight and that dependence
on the robots which you know could
malfunction but then you know it comes
with the consequences of if something
goes wrong who is liable
and considering that the growth of the
aging population
and the increase in life expectancy is
going to just
increase this demand for surgery these
are kind of questions that i think
should be you know more widely addressed
and discussed
especially since according at least to
this review in the future
any surgical procedure could contain at
least one robotic component
in the operation and so it's kind of
somewhat inevitable maybe
that this will technology will be
becoming it's a matter of how we deal
with the consequences
so i didn't really know this video kind
of felt a bit different to my usual kind
of videos
but i was just interested in the topic
and decided to talk about it
so i hope you have learned something and
it's entirely up to you if you want to
have a go at the survey i'm not
associated
with it in any particular way um but
yeah
i hope you found something and as always
thanks for listening